let's get to your top five takeaways rod
the cowboys we just were there we
watched the cowboys the minnesota
vikings it's kind of a weird game to
pick without dak what's your temperature
right now on the dallas cowboys cooper
rush they find a way to go get a win
man we talked when we talked to amari
cooper we talked about the level of
talent you and i we talked about the
level of talent that they have and i was
looking at the talent on the offensive
offensive side of the ball
the offensive line is ridiculous i mean
the offensive line absolutely no
weaknesses at the o-line running back
quarterback the wide receivers of studs
and think of think about cedric think
about cedric wilson a guy coming in for
michael gallup he's played well he's
helped take pressure off amari cooper
and those guys so i like what they're
doing this is this is probably the most
and amari cooper said he said this is
the most talented team that he's been on
in seven years of playing the national
football league and i would have to
agree with him they are loaded
yeah rob we thought we thought amari
cooper was kind of shy or whatever we're
like man i don't even know what he's
going to be like in this post-game
interview he was awesome man his
personality was shining the way he was
giving away some things about dallas i
was like i really felt like i got a good
picture of that team and mike mccarthy
coaching that team let's play a little
bit of that post-game interview that we
had right there on the field with the
mario cooper here's what he said about
the 2021 cowboys
what is it about this team that makes
you guys believe
in the fourth quarter that you can pull
out a game like this man we just believe
in we just believe in the guys that we
have um you know we preach that neutral
mindset no matter how the game is going
you know we're going to stay even kill
and like i said we believe in the guys
we have we believe in the talent on our
team the way we work and we just come
out here and prove it every week the
thing about um every great team that
i've noticed whether i was in pop warner
uh what whatever sport i was in
depth
you have depth
you're going to be successful you see
our quarterback went down coop came in
make some made some big plays um we have
corners go down i mean um michael gallop
isn't even playing you saw a set with
that huge touchdown we have a lot of
debt we have a lot of talent throughout
across the board
and jack you know what was interesting
man you know i asked him a question
about mike mccarthy and from the media
standpoint every you know so many people
give him such a hard time and
and he he had his coaches back he's just
like look i love mike mccarthy all he
wants to do is win all he talks about is
winning all everything that he does is
based on winning football games and i
was really shocked to hear that i
thought maybe he would say something
else i didn't know that he was going to
come to mike mccarthy's defense like he
did they love that man
they do and you got to say man like he
he went through a lot because his first
year in dallas when some people are
already saying that's a risky hire
that's not the guy they should have
brought in they lose dak prescott they
have a slew of injuries offensive
linemen are hurt everybody's banged up
and he's got to hear all that noise the
entire season then the entire offseason
but dak prescott comes back and in week
one i mean this team was ready in week
one they went toe to toe with tom brady
the tampa bay bucks a unit that was
basically returning their entire team
and i just thought that they went right
there with them and ever since they've
been playing even better now they go get
a win with their backup quarterback and
i think amari cooper made an awesome
point about the depth and the big thing
for me is this team was built around a
great offensive line and they hadn't had
that for a few years so zeke's numbers
were going down they weren't running the
ball anymore life was harder on dak
prescott now the offensive line has
returned to dominance and all of a
sudden you better look out man because
the dallas cowboys look like they may go
compete for championships with the way
they're playing right now and that was
without even having their star
quarterback in dak prescott i thought it
illuminated how talented this entire
group has become
you know i thought that you know that
prescott's injury i think it really
affected ezekiel elliott i really
believe it affected him because he came
back a different guy he was focused and
i think he realized that he had such a
great opportunity not to not to take not
not to take advantage of this
opportunity that he has because he's
such a great player and coming in out of
shape and things like that but when you
see a good guy and that's a good person
when you see him hurt and you see his
ankle twisted around and you know that
this guy loves football it affects you
and i think it really affected zeke it
humbled zeke and it made zeke come back
better than he's been in years
yeah and you can forget about teammates
too those two are just best friends i
mean dak and zeke goes to our best
friends so you can imagine just having
one of your best friends go through all
that let's get you to your second take
away right now zach let me let me
exactly
jack
let me just say this last point about
zeke okay and i have to make this point
when you watch zeke at home
it's it's really not
you can't really tell how big and how
aggressive and how physical but we're on
that sideline and that last run that he
had
it was just incredible like how hard
this guy runs he is a big thick dude and
he runs and he gets stronger and
stronger i just had to make that point
because watching them at home is
completely different than him watching
him on the sideline and just how big and
how aggressive and how physical he runs
i i think that's a really important
point but for one reason because amari
cooper is getting a lot of the credit
for that final drive but who had that
big third yeah who had that conversion
where he caught it well short and broke
those tackles to go get it you better
believe it was zeke he gets a ton of
criticism but i also thought throughout
the course of this game the vikings knew
the cowboys wanted to run the ball in a
backup quarterback they wanted to run
the ball guess what minnesota could do
nothing about it and that gives you some
idea about how good this running game's
become the offensive line and the backs
if you know we want to do it and you
still can't stop it that reminds you of
what the baltimore ravens are let's get
to tennessee derrick henry so derek
henry now going to miss a long time just
had surgery on that ankle
what does this mean for for where the
tennessee titans go from here because
they were very hot coming into that game
yeah when you lose your best player you
you lose a guy of this caliber this
really significantly hurts your your
team because i mean you lose that fear
factor not just the physical fear factor
is 6'3 240 pounds but every time he
touches the ball there's an opportunity
for him to go 40 60 70 yards for a
touchdown and defensively you don't have
to commit the eighth guy in the box
anymore you know they signed no they
signed adrian peterson think about it if
you can keep those safeties back
and worry about julio and aj and um
who's the um
aj brown yep yeah aj brown i'm sorry aj
brown when you can keep those safeties
back and worry about those guys you
don't have to worry about coming up and
hitting a 240 pound back that's huge
that's going to change the really the
nature of their offense and i i think
this is a huge blow for him
it is so you got to look at who's able
to step in right so it's jeremy
mcnichols jeremy mcnichols he's a
practice squad guy he's bounced around
everywhere he's out of boise state he's
played for about eight different teams i
don't think he's going to be
an answer i mean the drop off from
playing
yeah he can play but he's no derrick
henry and then you have a 36 year old
adrian peterson over 3 100 career
carries that's a lot of highway miles
over a 15-year career to try to carry
that backfield it's a problem like i
think the point you're making is ryan
tannehill has been a really good
quarterback and a really underrated
quarterback and really played awesome
within this scheme but when teams start
game planning to stop their passing
attack as opposed to derek henry what
does that mean and maybe he'll still be
able to go play like this but it's going
to be an entirely different feel the way
these teams are
trying to go now defend the titans
knowing that they don't have their ace
coming out of that backfield now he may
come back we may see derek henry for a
good playoff run or you know this
season's in eternity this season he may
still come back but they got to be able
to make it there without him and i think
that's still up in the air because he
has carried this team for years now
yeah and i think ryan tannehill he'll
they'll put a little bit more pressure
on him to probably make plays with his
legs because he's a very athletic guy we
saw that in miami
and whatever he has to do right whatever
he has to do to make those plays i think
he will do it but it also affects the
defense you think about the defense it
keeps them when you have derrick henry
it keeps the defense off the field okay
so now your defense is on the sideline
they're resting where as opposed to the
other defense they're getting physically
beaten up you're wearing them down
running the football and now you can use
the play-action pass the other thing
about their their offense too is julio
jones is hit or miss is he going to be
healthy this is every single week is he
practicing will he practice is he
healthy will he play and that's going to
be a big problem you can't have julio in
and out the lineup and not having that
chemistry with ryan tannehill and then
all of a sudden you don't have your star
running back as well so i think fercher
and those tight ends they'll be a little
bit more involved and let's talk and
then the defense there's going to be a
little bit more pressure on the defense
obviously and they're playing a lot
better
quickly things change in this league man
like last week we're talking about the
cincinnati bengals we're talking about
tennessee titans the bengals lose to the
jets the titans lose derek henry now
they got to go into la it's just this
season can change like that after just a
historic start that derek henry was off
to let's get to new england bill
belichick every time he goes up against
a rookie or an inexperienced or a young
quarterback he always just gives him
nightmares so how does he do it and how
did he do it to herbert this week
well we saw we saw it with zach wilson
we saw it twice with zach wilson you
know just what he does oh yeah and just
the emphasis that he puts on disguising
and bringing pressure and i was watching
that tape a little bit he kind of copied
or pulled some of those pressures from
the baltimore ravens game he had a lot
of six and seven man up you know where
guys were in those a gaps and looking
like they were gonna blitz coming out of
it and herbert looked confused he did
not look comfortable with all those
different looks he just didn't and
matthew judon he has been the star of
this defense i remember we were out
there against tampa bay and i had a
conversation with him i told him i said
you got to be the driving force they
paid you a lot of money you got to be
the energy you got to bring in every
single game every single practice and he
looked at me and just said yes sir and
he's balling out and he's been a
difference-making it was good to see
there he is adrian phillips former
charger get two interceptions and the
pick six would ultimately change the
game but the patriots defense they're
getting better they carried the offense
matt jones didn't have a great game he
had an efficient game but this defense
will have to carry the patriots right
onto the playoffs
yeah and it basically comes from judon
was the best player on baltimore's
defense consistently right and bill
belichick was just sick of going up
against him and he said forget it i'm
just gonna pay that guy bring him over
and i feel like belichick never once he
never wants to pay anybody like he never
wants to write that big check so when he
does you know it's going to be somebody
who is going to make a huge difference
like i think about stefan gilmore
getting that check even though he wound
up being underpaid by the end of his
contract he got a big contract from them
and he did some amazing things judon
gets a big payday you're thinking it's
going to be another one sure enough
judon's having a huge year for him let's
get to your fourth takeaway the bangles
a rude awakening just mentioned it the
jets guy had to go back and watch that
game today it was something watching
mike white just go off on that defense
why could this be a good thing though
for cincinnati
well i'm going to read you a quote by
joe mixon it actually kind of got my
attention he said no matter what we have
to have our team ready to go today we
just weren't ready we came out flat they
wanted it more that's just what it was
to me that speaks directly to the head
coach of not having them properly
prepared zach taylor come on man you
know your team is a young team they
haven't been very successful and you
have to emphasize guys we're gonna
practice extra hard we're gonna meet
extra just so you guys won't take this
team for granted and that's exactly what
they did and to me it's it's the it's
the players fault as well because they
got so caught up in believing all the
headlines oh jamar chase is the best
wide receiver in the league joe burrow
is this the offensive line is playing
well the defense they have to forget
about the headlines and they got to stay
focused on the task at hand
here's the thing about cincinnati right
now they could beat anybody and they can
lose to anybody i think that's the big
headline when you look at the bengals
team is that it's that consistency it's
that young team but i mean they should
have beaten green bay all they had to do
was make a kick they lost to the bears
when the bears were in just complete
just a dumpster fire they lost to the
bears and now you go lose to the jets
when they don't even have zach wilson so
they can beat anybody they can lose to
anybody you mentioned joe mixon i want
to call him out a little bit because if
you think about this passing game and
the emergence of it it's really become
one of the premier young passing games
in the entire league joe mixon he hasn't
had a hundred yard rushing game since
week one and i understand he does some
things out of the backfield did some
things out of the backfield against the
jets this past weekend catching the
football but they got to be able to get
this running game churning because going
for about 40 yards on the ground puts so
much pressure on joe burrow and i think
over the long run over trying to put
together a playoff run it's got to go
through mixing more as the weather gets
worse and worse which it will here in
cincinnati already is believe me i got
my coat sitting right next to me it's a
dumpster fire out here from weather
perspective in cincinnati yeah i'm
looking at condos in florida go ahead
rob
[Laughter]
well it must be nice let me ask you this
so do you believe that it's mixon's
responsibility to run better or do you
think it's zach taylor's responsibility
to call more run plays
probably some degree of both yeah
probably some degree of both i don't
think they're getting enough carries i
think that's real too i think he's
probably trying to get it to him in the
passing game a little too often as
opposed to just just coming out and
hammering the ball and letting that
develop a play-action game for boro
which would be much easier because guys
will be more open
yeah i just think that you know
sometimes you have games like this
you're on a road i mean even to veteran
teams that are used to having success
sometimes you just get caught slipping
and this is not always the worst thing
that can happen because what happens
when you lose to a team like that you
the organization the team kind of panics
a little bit so now you got the coaches
bring you in watching a little extra
tape and that's a good thing because
what it does is it's a wake-up call it
wakes you up and makes you understand
that hey we can't take anyone for
granted because just like you said we're
capable of beating anybody but we're
also capable of losing to someone
yeah and it could it could end up being
the perfect thing too because if you're
cincinnati you would much rather lose to
the jets and come beat the browns as
opposed to beat the jets and come lose
to the browns next weekend so it's a big
game against cleveland hopefully they
are mad going into let's get to your
fifth takeaway which is the browns
you're saying the browns gotta somehow
just become a group that's as one
because right now they're beat up
they're banged up and they're losing
rodney
yeah the browns that's the most
important thing everybody's gonna from
the outside everyone's going to say this
and that about the browns the most
important opinion is what do they think
about themselves sticking together as a
team and not answering questions about
other people in odell bro odell
beckham's situation hey i thought they
should have traded him kevin stevenski
has to do a better job of getting him
involved like what are you doing kevin
like i was on national television last
year every single week talking about
kevin stefanski should be the coach of
the year should be the coach of the year
and you got a talent like odell beckham
you have to get him the ball jet sweeps
whatever it is quick passes screens get
him the ball take a few shots with him
get him more involved in the game it's
too much talent sitting on the bench and
not getting production from odell
beckham
you know truthfully rod i think they
wanted to i think they wanted to get rid
of them i don't think there's a team out
there that's wants him i really don't
like they don't want him bad enough to
go make a legitimate offer to the browns
that's what i think he's making too much
money
for the headache that he can be and then
you got all this stuff with his dad's
posting these clips on youtube and it's
real i mean he's been open we've been
talking about this since about week two
he is open and he's not getting the ball
that's real 100
so odell beckham jr's dad has got a
point now is this going to help the
chemistry no i i will say to rodney when
we had that interview what was it maybe
the preseason game or something where we
interviewed baker mayfield on the field
right after the game and we asked him
about odell beckham jr there was some
temperature about that answer when i
asked how do you successfully reinsert
odell beckham jr into this offense there
was something weird about that answer i
was going
it's not a number one priority and he's
been back and healthy and it has been
far from a number one priority so i'm
right there with you move them if you're
not gonna use them but i don't think the
market was that vast to be honest
when i look at a guy like jarvis landry
and i'm so sick in hearing people jump
on jarvis landry like jarvis landry he's
been
their emotional leader he's been one of
the best players since he's been in
cleveland and this guy's been reliable
he's been tough he doesn't mind blocking
he goes down and blocks outside
linebackers you never hear jarvis landry
com complain about anything so people
who's ever talking trash about him yeah
he had a bad game he had a few drops but
i guarantee you this he'll show up next
week i know jarvis landry he will show
up next week he's one of the toughest
players if not the toughest player on
their on on their team another guy just
want to give props to his miles garrett
he is balling out now we need to start
inserting his name in the conversation
for defensive player of the year because
he's balling
that's a great point right right up
there with max crosby he is right there
in that conversation the biggest story
at the browns is that they are just hurt
at so many positions including
quarterback as baker's battling through
that left shoulder injury
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports